isn't going debuted last night with a
10-point winner for Southern University
10 players in double figures very
balanced for Keyshawn Gilbert Leading
The Way with 13. they also provided fans
with a few highlights along the way
we give the guys a lot of freedom we try
to just create advantages to where they
can just make plays I think this is a
high basketball IQ group I think it's a
group that can make a lot of plays for
each other so we're just going to
continue hammering that point home about
uh just being stubborn
stubborn might witnessing games they are
going to hang their hats on defense so
that was their first game they play
again this weekend uh hopefully they can
keep winning we're optimistic for him
this season keeping our fingers crossed
for the nights they've got a 3-3 late in
the third we'll see what happens what a
season start for the golden knights best
and they're the best team right now in
the NHL nice so that's great yeah that
is nice thanks Chris more to